um with oil prices uh we were at our
conference lunch today and someone said
you know oil is going to go to four
dollars a gallon and senator boxer
sitting next to me said it's already
four dollars a gallon in my hometown in
california
well um it is well over three dollars a
gallon in most of our
in most of our constituencies and uh um
and we're paying
uh that money in my view because we lack
an energy policy
what up peeps i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report it is june 8 2022 we're
live streaming on rumble rumbleblazetv
and youtube subscribe if you have not
and that
was
the guy that used to be known as joe
biden i suppose he's still known as joe
biden at some level but he is clearly a
shell of him of his former self that's
him like 30 years ago when he could get
a sentence together pretty cleanly uh
and in that case he was really talking
about how it is on the people who are in
charge of the government to do something
related to energy policy when the gas
prices are going high
but apparently the elderly man
pretending to be president joe biden now
doesn't know that he's in charge thus
they're kind of waving their hands we
got a jam-packed show we just did the
run through and i'm feeling very good
about what you are going to
get today we are going to talk about the
democrats crazy messaging their crazy
policies
how they're going to scare you to keep
you around and then there were a bunch
of elections
yesterday and they did not go well for
the last five remaining good liberals i
have tried to talk to these people i
have said to you people hey you're a
sane liberal well basically you're just
kind of a modern conservative and you
can ally with people on the right who
can agree to disagree
you have to stop trying to make sense
out of the democratic party you have to
stop trying to work with the
progressives there's nothing left there
is no bottom to that
but a bunch of them keep trying and i
think after yesterday perhaps a few of
them will look in the mirror and realize
that it ain't gonna work uh before we
get to all that though i do want to
remind you guys that because the tour
was so successful we are adding one
final stop in my adopted hometown of
miami we got an image for you
my voice is cracking a little bit today
uh july 14th at the miami improv tickets
are selling fast i will have at least
one special guest from sunny hot
summer humid miami daverubin.com
events if you want to join us uh and
that's
the theme of the show today they these
people don't know what they're doing
they are lying we are going to mock the
hell out of them but before we do that i
want to talk to you about alto ira uh
guys you know cryptocurrency may
represent the future of money it's one
of the most exciting investment
opportunities to come around for some
time but what about taxes with an alto
crypto ira you can trade crypto like
bitcoin and avoid or defer the taxes
there are multiple ways to fund your
account you can make a cash contribution
transfer cash from an existing ira or
roll over an old 401k you can trade all
you want without the tax headache and
you can create an account in just a few
minutes ready to take your investments
to the next level diversify like the
pros and trade without tax headaches
open an alto crypto ira with as little
as 10 bucks just go to alto ira dot com
slash ruben that's a ltoira.com
reuben start investing in crypto today
go to alto ira.com ruben and now back to
me
all right so yesterday i saw a clip
of this uh woman who replaced jen saki
and she's a black lesbian and i don't
care about the color of your skin and i
don't care who you're sleeping with that
goes for everybody goes for you and you
and you watching this right now what i
do care is if you are in a position of
power that you are let's say
roughly competent that would be nice
that you wouldn't lie all the time that
your
driving force in life wouldn't be to
deny truth especially if you were say i
don't know white house press secretary
well this woman corrine jean-pierre in
the two weeks on the job basically is
worse than jen saki it is incredible i
cannot believe it but she is worse
listen to this lie
what we're trying to say what i'm trying
to say to you is that the economy is in
a better place than it has been
historically and so we feel here at this
administration and other experts as well
is that we feel that we are in a good
position to take on inflation we are in
a good position
i mean
lie lie
do you think that was a lie
i
i mean that's so off the charts bananas
liar liar
pantsuit on fire stuff right there but
what's interesting is even within the
way she's saying it she's telling you
it's a lie right because she's not
saying it's a fact that the economy is
doing well what she says is what we're
trying to say
doesn't mean it's true we're just trying
to say it right we're just trying to say
it we feel
that the economy is doing well we feel
that the right markers are out there to
turn this thing around that is such an
absolute lie and as i've been saying to
you a lot lately i don't even need to
show you the numbers on that you know
it's a lie right there is just
no
way around it in essence but then she
got questioned on it a bit more and she
explained herself about why she was
saying something that we obviously know
isn't true you're saying that people
feel good about their personal
financial situation high gas prices
people can't get baby formula the supply
chain is messed up uh
everything is more expensive but
where's the good part
so the survey that i just read off
started in 2013 and that is the first
time that we saw numbers like this since
2013. so that does no that does mean
something just like you gave me 83
percent
i'm
61 are saying now in this wall street
journal pool they are generally
pessimistic about people having an
opportunity to achieve the american
dream how's that going to look on a
bumper i guess what i'm trying to say
peter is that we understand that people
are feeling feeling this
that is fan
freaking fantastic so first off of
course the guy asking her the question
that's peter ducey over at fox who i
often say he is like the number one
journalist right now and how refreshing
to be able to say the word journalist
and not do the air quotes thing right so
at the end there what she says is after
he knocks her off her ridiculous high
horse uh with facts her quote it's just
so perfect it's exactly what she did in
the previous segment what i'm trying to
say is that we understand people are
feeling this what i'm trying to say is
it has nothing to do with reality uh we
understand we feel that you're feeling
it we know that uh it's pretty bad out
there but you know uh despite the
badness out there uh we feel that we're
gonna say things that aren't true to
make you feel better than they are but
this thing this big lie right they think
we are all about the big lie they are
about the big lie because their big lie
is a gazillion lies which sort of
morph into one big lie much like
devastator who was a constructicon a
decepticon who was created out of five
different trucks that created the big
devastator you remember that google if
you don't know what i'm talking about
but they lie about absolutely everything
to the point now where not only are they
lying they're realizing that none of
this stuff is working but what do they
have well janet yellen she has something
very very special late to the end of
this one there's no question that we
have
huge inflation pressures
that inflation is really our top
economic problem at this point and that
it's critical that we address it so
i do expect i do expect inflation to
remain high although i very much hope
that it will be coming down now
she has hope
she has hope
john crin she feels something this
woman's got hope the ship is sinking
people do you see what's going on here
as andy dufresne said hope is a good
thing okay if you haven't seen shawshank
redemption in a while you probably
should but the point is their policies
are not working and even though they own
the media right even though they own the
entire messaging apparatus they're
starting to crack they really are they
are under water and they're trying to
cover their butts and the messaging
ain't working people we got more on that
in just a second let me talk to you
about jen yourself for a moment you know
do you ever take a look in the mirror
and notice dark spots on your face it
can certainly be a concern for me since
i'm now an official resident of hot and
sunny florida the sun can bring out some
spots on your face well i got some good
news for you there's only one week left
virginia sells summer clearance sale you
can save over 60 percent off jen
yourselves most popular package at
gendacell.com order today and get
genusell's dark spot corrector to
visibly reduce those pesky dark spots
for free the janusel dark spot corrector
uses special peptides to visibly reduce
the appearance of dark spots age spots
and yes even sunspots that the summer
leaves behind januselle has been family
owned and operated since day one they
know times are tough for all of us and
that's why they have not and will not
raise prices on their world-class skin
care results are real millions of
americans including myself are in love
genusl guarantees results are your money
back and sign up for geniusel's best in
class rewards program at checkout for an
extra 10 off your order and receive a
complimentary gift set go to genyasel
g-e-n-u-c-e-l dot com slash dave and
enter david check out for those extra
summer savings and right now uh their
most popular package includes janusel's
immediate effects treatment for results
in as little as 10 hours 12 hours go to
januscell.com dave and now back to me
okay
so if you didn't think jean corinne
and janet yellen if you didn't think
that their messaging was bad we feel
things we've got hope we know the whole
thing's going to [ __ ] but we're sitting
here and we're talking that's what we do
here is michigan democrat
debbie stabenow and she is at a hearing
about gas prices and inflation and all
that stuff and don't worry guys she's
doing okay she's doing just fine because
she's got an electric car and also has a
fresh perm
i do have to say just on the issue of
gas prices after waiting for a long time
to have enough trips in this country to
finally get my electric vehicle i got it
and drove it from michigan to here uh
this last weekend and went by every
single gas station it didn't matter how
high it was and so i'm looking forward
to the opportunity for us to move to
vehicles that aren't going to be
dependent on the
whims of the oil companies and the
international markets
my god that woman is a very very special
combination of smug condescending evil
and stupid
with everything going on in the country
right now as she sits there in her
obviously very expensive pant suit and
her hair that had just been done which
i'm sure cost now you know probably a
thousand bucks how much does it cost for
a chick to get a do like that it cost me
that was the fastest i ever say you give
up
how am i supposed to know i go to
supercuts man the point is it costs a
lot of money to get a hairdo like that
okay uh and she is telling people with
that smile on her face don't worry about
me i have an electric car right now and
uh i'll be okay you suckers
man these people are so
smug and evil i want to say for a moment
just on a personal note about this i i
have a tesla i have a model x tesla it
is not cheap i lease it by the way
that was just the choice that we made
probably not the best choice because
teslas are going to be around for a long
time and the resale value on them will
continue to go but our choice was to
lease it um it is extremely expensive
we probably could have got four sort of
regular suvs for what i'm paying per
month on this thing but it was a choice
that we made it's a really cool car and
a cool innovation and i am extremely
blessed that i'm doing pretty decently
thanks to the kindness of strangers like
you guys
and it's an awesome car and all of those
things but i know i'm in a very special
category of this
okay um the idea that these people these
these politicians a democrat politician
in michigan
michigan which has a really banged up
economy i mean go to detroit it's like
you know it's basically going to some
sort of dystopian sci-fi future um that
they can sit there and smile and talk
about their cars as it's their policies
that are driving up the price of gas for
your car it never ends with these people
but if you think that one was bad i mean
man we are painting a picture today if
these clowns in these clips that i have
not shown you uh was was bad enough so
far here's biden commerce secretary gina
raimondo and i kind of respect her on
this one because she she just kind of
admits we don't know what the hell we're
doing what is actually still on the
table though to bring gas prices down at
this point because the president has
said and made very clear that there's
not much left that he can do
yes good morning thank you for having me
unfortunately that is the brutal reality
that's my favorite clip of the day yes
good morning i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm doing what are you why am i even
here do i have a job what are these
people doing
these people pretending to be in charge
there's nothing we can do how am i
supposed to i'm the commerce secretary
what do you want me to do about this i
thought i was a secretary not someone
supposed to be in charge of anything
okay but of all of their messaging so
far if it's just all terrible you guys
get it it's all terrible they're
throwing crap on us at all times but
then their other thing if the uh you
know lying about the economy as they
destroyed as if that's not bad enough
the big thing with the democrats now is
sexualizing children and you know call
me old school but back in my day that
was something that was frowned upon but
everybody every democrat they seem to
love it now a bunch of [ __ ] you know
dancing around or whatever they are drag
queens you know dancing around with kids
and blah blah blah
this is you may remember this one we
this is from about like a month and a
half ago during the don't say gay
brouhaha here in florida this is a
florida state senator his name's gary
farmer and he wrote florida's don't say
gay bill is a cruel attempt to erase
lgbtq children and families in our
communities i will not back down from
fighting to protect children and
families in our state
from this unwarranted hate let florida
free let free florida say gay put that
image up again look at this clown and
then he puts black tape over his mouth
and says gay on it i mean there used to
be clubs in chelsea you'd have to pay
people to do that for you uh so i
responded to him because i believe that
we should engage with these people i
said hey senator as a new floridian i'd
love to have you on my show to discuss
why you want a state employee to talk to
a first grader about sexuality and then
be able to hide that conversation from
the child's parents let me know when
you're available
that tweet got about 20 000 retweets his
original tweet got like two likes uh he
did not respond so i'm trying i'm really
trying my best to engage with these
people and i would have you know taken
the tape off his mouth and sat down with
him and treated him as respectfully as i
would treat anyone else
on the program but it's not just these
people then there is the televised
mental institution known as
msnbc and they have this
certified lunatic i mean a racist crazy
woman who does a show in the middle of
the day i think
joy reid and
she just wants you to know that
you know republicans they love death
and okay set aside ideological or
emotional safety we're not allowed to
feel physically safe anywhere in america
thanks to republicans ironclad
partnership with the bloodsoak nra which
long ago quit the gun safety business
and has been working for decades to
ensure that the most lethal arms get
into as many alienated 18 and 19 year
old in-cell hands as possible so that we
can't feel safe at walmart at the
supermarket
at bible study or church service
at the salon
at the hospital if god forbid some guy
gets mad at his doctor for not giving
him opioids at a nightclub at a concert
even at a funeral
or at school
whether you're in high school or you're
10
and in the fourth grade
in america and only in america you are
literally rolling the dice
every time you leave your house or drop
off your kids at school and you just
have to pray
that today is not your day or their day
to meet that angry alienated american
man with an ar15
you see what they do
imagine the mental state you'd have to
be in if you watch that channel all day
long the endless psychotic
fear
that keeps you watching
uh also it's not literally roll the dice
unless people are literally playing
crops all day long lady it's
metaphorically roll the dice i use the
word literally liberally sometimes
myself but that's just an aside but if
you're watching that and you're
listening to her and then you walk
outside you think you're going to be
shot you go to the hair salon and you
think you're going to be shot you go to
the hospital and you think you're going
to be shot strangely i'm guessing that
joy reid i'm willing to make a 10 bet on
this one there was a crazy stabbing at
the encino hospital which is where i
used to live in los angeles a couple
days ago a crazy person just bust into
the hospital and stabbed a couple nurses
and doctors
i'm guessing she didn't cover that now
it didn't have the weapon of choice and
it happened in cali and she wouldn't
want people to think bad things are
happening in cali because it's got all
sorts of
laws around people doing bad things um
but these people their hypocrisy is off
the charts and also the idea that the
nra now you again we can all have an
honest assessment and disagreement about
some of the things related to guns okay
and whether it should be
18 to buy a gun or 21 to buy a gun or
why you'd be able to say buy a gun at a
certain age but you still can't vote or
buy a beer et cetera et cetera there's
legitimate stuff to talk about but they
want you to constantly be in fear and
they also want to constantly attack the
organizations that are defending our
right to defend ourselves right
governments should not uh people should
not fear their governments governments
should fear their people if you haven't
seen v for vendetta in a while i highly
recommend it um and that is what they
are trying to take away from us the nra
how many of the mass shooters were nra
members i'm gonna guess it's zero i'd
love to be fact checked on this we can
try it real time if you want how many
mass shooters in the united states were
members of the nra i would bet you it is
zero the nra takes their job very
seriously you may not like some of the
things they do i don't need to make this
about the nra and i'm not going to sit
here defending every every policy
decision that they've done but the point
is there are all sorts of organizations
that help good people learn about what
their rights are good people learn about
uh weapons safety etc etc so uh this
attack this idea
that the republicans just want to work
with the honoree and they want
blood-soaked people and they want you to
be freaking out when you're going to the
ymca or when you're going to chipotle it
ain't true oh and thank you for chat
fact checking me live we love that from
quora.com uh zero mass shooters were
registered uh nra members so chalk one
up for me uh but okay it's not just
their messaging on the economy that's
terrible and they don't know what's
going on and they're admitting it and
they're telling you we feel a certain
way even though it has nothing to do
with reality and it's not just they're
lying to you about you know when you're
going to go out and get shot
they're also lying to you and they've
been lying to you forever about masks so
there's this and covid and all that
stuff so there's this woman stacy abrams
nobody knows what her qualifications are
nobody knows why they know her but the
media just loves her right they just
love this woman uh here she is this is
yesterday or the day before
and she's in a photo op why anyone want
to take a picture with this woman who as
far as i can tell has accomplished
nothing other than losing
a race in georgia and then claiming that
she won but when you're a democrat
you're allowed to do that but people
want to take pictures with her
apparently and here's this kid trying to
take a picture with her and of course
the kid well you take a look
i'm going to do something mildly
obnoxious come here
come on yeah
you've got a phone right come on
you seem really
excited you mind taking your mask off
for a second
mom's okay
i've got a little bit of trouble taking
him out for kids with a mask on here
okay
so i'm just showing you the endless
hypocrisy of these people so that fat
woman and i only mentioned that she's
fat because she is fat and obesity is
one of the major things that when kovid
was a real thing remember when remember
kovid remember coven member berries you
guys remember kovid remember coven um
that we were told that you know obesity
was one of the reasons uh one of the
comorbidities that you would be more
affected by covid right of course then
they closed all the gyms and they had us
all order in chinese food every day but
okay put that aside for a second uh she
had been caught a couple times
maskless taking pictures with kids so
just the the this absolute
absurdity the hubris of these people
she's i don't know what event she's
doing it doesn't even matter some
idiotic progressive nonsensical palooza
whatever it is but she's there she's got
no mask on you've got kids there with
masks and then when the kid approaches
her then you take the mask off this is
the same thing that we see with joe
biden all the time right he walks out of
air force one with the mask even though
we know he wasn't wearing a mask when he
was in there then he gets down to the
stairs and he
gets up to the dignitary of whatever
country he's in he takes off the mask he
shakes their hands he says hello to them
he kisses he sniffs the hair
[Music]
god evil people
the point is
that it doesn't look good for voters who
were kids these kids were not allowed to
go to school or these kids had to wear
masks and then you have this obese woman
not wearing a mask and then inviting the
children up to take off their vest if
you if the point is if you buy into any
of their [ __ ] then they're showing
you right in front of your face that
it's [ __ ] but they all they also
just keep everyone in a constant state
of hysteria and it's not just about guns
and it's not just about covid the one
that they're really going to be pushing
on us
going forward is climate change because
these people are freaking out right the
earth used to cool now it's getting
hotter then it's getting cooler then
it's hotter okay but these people if
they just had enough power if they just
had enough tax money if those evil
republicans weren't doing stuff with
those fossil fuels everything would be
okay so here is new york times op-ed
writer and i think he was former founder
of vox if i'm not mistaken ezra klein
and look at this post look at this post
this is he wrote this in the new york
times over the past few years i've been
asked one question more than any other
it comes up its speeches at dinners in
conversation
it's the most popular query when i open
my podcast to suggestions time and again
it comes in two forms the first should i
have kids given the climate crisis they
will face the second should i have kids
knowing they will contribute to the
climate crisis the world faces i would
like to be very clear about my next
statement because as you know i toured
with jordan peterson and he always says
that you have to be very careful with
your words
leftism is a mental disorder these
people are living in an alternate
reality and there is
no
stopping them from that reality you can
maybe rescue a couple people you can
toss you know it's just think of a sort
of bottomless pit right and occasionally
you can you know toss in your lure you
can throw your fishing rod and you can
toss in something and maybe you can pull
somebody out but these people if you are
walking around thinking that you
shouldn't have kids because of the
environment or you're gonna have less
kids because of the environment or
you're not gonna go so you're on a trip
because of the gas or whatever you are
in a completely insane mental state so
let's just assume that what he's not
first off i don't even know if i'll
assume that he's saying something true
that that is the query he gets most
when he opens his podcast that i'm sure
nobody's listening to
and when he does his shows or whatever
and it's all about that and it's like
man
you know i've just been on the road
nobody asked me about climate change
nobody was actually tons of people i met
tons of people who were pregnant who
were expanding their family who were
very excited about the future of america
who were excited to get past all this
woke [ __ ] and live good lives but
progressivism needs a certain level of
fear and anxiety and depression that is
the fuel for it the fuel for what we're
doing is freedom freedom live freely man
figure it out good luck to you i'll meet
you on the other side but for them it is
my god i'm gonna be shot or i'm going to
die of covid or the environment or maybe
dinosaurs are coming back i don't know
we could be in a lot of trouble the
robots
it's endless it's absolutely endless uh
and then of course you know if you were
to even say uh you know i'm not that
concerned about climate change i don't
know maybe we'll see what happens you
know sometimes
these charts turn out to be wrong or the
data's missing most likely they'll call
you a racist or a bigot or a homophobe
and speaking of homophobes uh here is
espn now espn of course that used to be
a sports uh broadcasting network uh
actually little known fact when i was in
college i wanted to be an espn anchor
that's what i wanted to be i wanted to
be a sports center anchor i ended up i
guess doing something somewhat similar
but espn which is no longer a sports
network it's just like this woke
programming bonanza of insanity they
have a great show i haven't seen it in
years but
10 or 15 years ago when i cared about
this stuff they had the show called
around the horn so they get these uh
four different sports broadcasters from
different parts of the nation and the
host just throws questions at them he
gives them points at the end and then
the winner gets to say a little
something at the end of the show it's
just a great little gimmick for a show
this woman sarah spade she's an espn
contributor she was on the show and the
tampa bay uh rays they are
baseball team here in florida they are
putting the gay symbol the gay ray it's
a gay ray right it's a gay ray i don't
even know if they're a gay raise it's a
gay thing on the they're putting a gay
patch over here it's a gay patch the gay
patch it'll make you gay if you wear it
for four hours they're putting the gay
patch on the uh on the uniforms over
there and some of the players didn't
want to do it so you'll never guess what
she said about them
she's tampa pitcher jason adam to the
tampa bay times hard decision because
ultimately we all said we want is them
to know that they are welcome and loved
here but when we put it on our bodies i
think a lot of guys decided that it's
just a lifestyle that maybe not that
they look down on or anything or
differently it's just that maybe we
don't want to encourage if it we believe
in jesus who's encouraged us to live a
lifestyle that would abstain from that
behavior
sarah spain how does that all come off
to you
pride is about inclusion so you don't
love them and you don't welcome them if
you're not willing to wear the patch and
calling it a lifestyle reveals to me
that you've done not even a modicum of
research or understanding on this topic
it's what tends to happen when a
privileged class isn't affected by
things this is not just about baseball
that religious exemption bs which is
used in sport and otherwise also allows
for people to be denied health care jobs
apartments
children
prescriptions all sorts of rights and so
we have to stop tiptoeing around it
because we're trying to protect people
who are trying to be bigoted from asking
for them to be exempt from it when the
very people that they are bigoted
against are suffering the consequences
when you say trying to be bigoted
all right so the funny part of that that
you might have only caught if you're a
seasoned around the horn viewer is so
the host as i said his name's tony
reality he gives people points
throughout the show and then the winner
gets to talk and she had the least
amount of points so tony knows what he's
doing but anyway everything she says
there it's just the endless woke
nonsense okay everyone is entitled to
their own religious beliefs everyone is
entitled uh to say what they believe on
this earth and if you don't believe in
say putting a black lives matter logo on
you uh that is one thing right this is
the same woman if if colin kaepernick
stood up for what she
for which she i'm not a biologist for
what he believes uh this woman would be
applauding it's colin kaepernick
standing up for what he believes it's
fantastic now one of these players is
just saying hey i uh you're entitled to
your own life but i have my own
religious views ah you're bad for saying
what you believe so you have to have
tried it's i know it's tough but if you
have consistent principles you'll not be
endlessly hysterical because you'll
realize that other people have other
feelings and then the world continues to
go round and round uh then she just
makes up like a series of things about
how people are uh punished and can't get
things based on their sexuality you
can't get a job or you can't get what
was it
health care and apartment and blah blah
blah no we have laws around all of these
things um
so it's just more of the nonsense
but if you think i'm over
promoting their nonsense to you today
well the january 6th hearings are
happening right now i haven't covered
them they're complete nonsense it was
unclear to me whether they were on the
cartoon network or comedy central so i'm
not watching them but there's a certain
set of crazy people who are always
worried about covid and being shot and
the racist people coming to get them and
the white supremacists that are very
they're very focused on this thing now
you may remember january 6
2021 it was when a couple thousand
people walked into the capitol some of
them did it violently but most and by
and large did not often the officers
were kind of letting them walk right in
nobody had weapons really there was no
plan apparently one guy had a lego set
of the capital i mean that guy should
really be you know an adult playing lego
something's going on but the point is uh
it's it's a farce it's an absolute
distraction and a farce but they need a
distraction in the farce because of all
the reasons i've been talking about here
because so much is going so wrong with
their policies uh here's representative
he's a democrat of course representative
steve cohen and of course he wants you
to be very scared about trump and the
white people
the justice department dhs saying it's
no better today
the environment particularly as it
relates to elections violence around
elections like you witnessed yourself on
january six no better today than it was
prior to january six i i wonder for
folks watching at home now should they
be concerned that these midterms coming
up might be marred by
violence
we all should be concerned about the
midterms being harmed and all public
officials should be concerned about
their own safety of fear uh jonathan
martin our friend who wrote this shall
not pass makes that clear in his book
that this is something that is a
continuing part of american government
american politics the big lie continues
the fealty to trump continues and the
encouragement to the white supremacists
and the terrorists to be involved
continues
did someone find me a white supremacist
guys can one of you find me a white
supremacist where are they can someone
get me a white supremacist i would like
to find a white supremacist i will take
a white supremacist out to lunch to
learn what they're thinking because
these people are always talking about
white supremacists i cannot find any
a a legitimate white supremacist now are
they somewhere are there they're there i
guess there's a white supremacist
somewhere are there racist people of
course but this idea that there are
white supremacists people who want white
people to reign supreme and who are in
the united states government and
secretly planning so that there will be
laws for white people and laws for black
people it simply doesn't exist unless
you're a progressive in which case you
do think that there should be certain
laws and benefits based on skin color
that's a leftist idea okay there is no
one there is literally no mainstream
conservative republican who is pushing
anything close to the racist nonsense
that the lefties are pushing every day
but they need you to be very fearful
because they know they're going to get
shellacked
they're going to get shellacked i don't
want to be too overconfident and you
shouldn't be overconfident we've got to
make sure we go out there and vote but
they're going to get shellacked so
they're prepping their people oh they're
going to be violent oh they're not going
to accept the results of the election or
they're going to rig the election etc
etc and they think that might be a
winning message if you can keep
everybody thinking kovid's coming back
and white people are coming to get you
and you're going to be shot and all of
this stuff it's very it's very
lofty and uh you know very exciting
wouldn't you say but every now and again
something happens on mainstream media
that allows you to see through the veil
there is a woman who has been guest
hosting on the program known as the view
which is where five generally crazy
women who used to not be insane sit and
bicker at each other
and her name is lindsey granger and she
is a conservative she's been a guest
host and she has been knocking it out of
the park over there we got to get her on
the show can we reach out to her um and
she yesterday was talking to joy and
whoopi and the other oh and sunny
hosting and watch sunny sunny hosting
who's a racist and really you can just
tell she's a terrible person when i show
you this clip really watch sunny hustle
the way she looks at lindsay granger the
whole purpose of the view was that we
were going to get different women this
is what barbara walters always said
we're going to get different women from
different views to sit and respectfully
talk and that's what the show did for a
long time i want you to really look at
the way sunny hosting looks at lindsey
granger for having a different point of
view but lindsey granger's main point
here is that focusing on january 6 is a
losing message for the democrats she's
trying to tell the democrats hey do a
little bit better and just watch the way
they respond to her i think the average
fox news viewer has been seeing for a
year and a half this play out over and
over again rioters attack our capital
we've seen it on every single channel
even fox local if you watch that so
people understand exactly what happened
and so what is the smoking gun here what
is the breaking news i know what we're
waiting for people will turn in once the
department of justice says okay here are
the charges well i have to wait
let me finish we want some criminal
charges if that's what you want that's
what we'll see next we're not even going
to see that in these nine hearings and
then if we think about the actual
intention of this there's a sentiment
that democrats need to rebrand this
midterm message right so by airing this
you're going to remind everybody like
hey
trump is aligned with other
conservatives and even though that's not
always true there's plenty of people who
spoke out against this and so now
reminder don't vote for these people in
the midterms because you want to keep
the majority and i think that that is a
losing message by looking in the past
and not looking in the future because
there's things on top of mine for people
there are things like feeding your baby
which i talked about yesterday there are
things on top of mine like people wanted
to know a recession is looming there are
things on top of mine like wondering how
to pay for your gas
refreshing hearing people tell the truth
i mean this is a conservative woman
sitting with four or five liberals uh
and the way that sunny hosted that face
that sunny hostin face
like what how condescending
how like what is the purpose what is the
purpose of sitting at a table every day
with other people with other views if
you're if when someone says something
you don't like that is your reaction to
it right and everything
that lindsay said there not only was
true she's tipping off she's tipping
these people up hey guys your message of
focusing on january 6 nobody really
cares about it and i love when she says
what's the smoking gun and joyce says i
don't know we'll she basically he's like
i don't know we'll find out that's what
we're looking for it's like if we don't
know the freaking smoking gun a year and
a half into this nonsense there ain't no
smoking gun just like there were no guns
brought by any of the protesters on
january 6th but there's more and it
involves a woman who normally is on the
view anna navarro uh she was on cnn i
don't know how this woman bounces around
from network to network with so little
skill but they keep putting her on uh
and she got into a little bit of a
debate with jonah goldberg about guns
and again listen to the way they need
hysteria jonah tries to explain hey
there's other problems other ways people
can get killed but hannah ain't having
any of it you're absolutely right to be
outraged about the crime but if we're
going to tell people they should be
terrified about their kids being dropped
off at school we should remind them that
their kids are more in danger on the
drive to school statistically
a child's life cannot be a statistic
right you can't tell the parents of
joaquin oliveira of parkland you can't
tell fred gutenberg you can't tell them
i'm making a basic point to say that you
shouldn't tell people that they should
be terrified if it were your child it
was not gonna it would not be a
statistic it would be a tragedy
why is it more like moral bullying
making it sound as if i don't have
compassion for these people
you shouldn't tell the audience that
this is the thing that they should be so
terrified with paralyzed with fear about
their own kids when their kids are more
likely to die from a lot of other things
or jonah goldberg trying to say
something true
on cable news well on cnn or msnbc and
it ain't easy of course he's right of
course he's right there's all sorts of
reasons psychologically and actually
factually that you wouldn't why you
wouldn't want to tell your children that
they're going to go out and get killed
when they go to school and everything
else the damage you could be doing to
these kids and anna navarro they this is
what they do with everything right you
overly emote the children are not a
statistic the children are not a
statistic he didn't say the children are
a statistic he was trying to talk about
actually how people die and what your
chances of getting shot are and
everything else but this is what they
and then they you know they're very
enraged and blah blah and and jonah's
lying that this is moral bullying it was
actually a great line because that's
what they do with everything it's moral
bullying she's trying to imply that he
doesn't care about kids who are shot and
that's not what he's saying at all this
is what they absolutely do or they bring
on actors and now here is an actor i
haven't shown you a hollywood a good
old-fashioned hollywood actor in a while
well here is robert de niro okay
robert de niro went on the stephen
colbert program i don't think anyone's
watching it actually my buddy greg
gutfeld he is the number one show on
late night television right now it's
crushing cold air even though colbert
probably has 100 people that work for
him and gutfeld literally has i think
four people that work on the show it's
awesome uh but de niro went on colbert
to defend joe biden because he's an
actor and actors act and they act and
they make up scripts and they hopefully
try to pass it as truth but i think
you're gonna see right through it like i
know that you you you have a fair amount
of uh you have emotions about politics
you have thoughts of course first those
stir emotions i know you have some
anxiety about state of politics in the
united states having a new guy at 1600
pennsylvania avenue has that have you
sleep any better at night yes
he's uh you know he he got us into calm
waters that was always the idea yeah
he's doing a very good job it's a tough
one i couldn't imagine i i could imagine
how difficult it is
um
i have decisions in my own personal life
that i imagine that what he goes through
is a hundred times that yeah and and so
uh no he's doing the best he can and and
uh
we got to get through a bad period
period yeah
well joe's doing the best he can but you
know the audience applause he's got
biter now it's all very exciting uh
let's not forget uh de niro he is quite
a political
analysis okay this is a guy who knows
what he's doing he thinks through the
issues he makes calm and reasoned
arguments why he likes joe biden you
just heard it there you know it's tough
it's just doing fine uh and you may
remember this one this was one of we had
to go through there's a whole bunch of
them this is one of his best i thought
this the way he sort of really captures
everything about donald trump right here
[Music]
i'm going to say one thing [ __ ] trump
[Applause]
you get it i think you get it all right
so now let me try to bring us into the
home stretch here
one of the things that i've really been
trying to talk about for the last year
here
is that good liberalism will not work
there is no evidence that it works
the people that try to be the non-woke
liberals they fail at every level and
what they can do in my estimation and it
is what i have done is ally with
conservatives say hey
i disagree with you on a couple things
or we have our own personal beliefs that
are a little bit different but we kind
of want to live in the same country and
what can
grow out of that what can flower out of
that is that a guy like me who certainly
is not a traditional conservative can
tour around the country on a
best-selling book
and have an audience that is probably 95
percent conservative and they all show
up and we sell out all the shows and it
goes really well and we all revel in our
differences and and really revel in the
fact that we want to keep this country
uh as great as it was and could be
again uh but but it seems like there's a
certain set of liberals that cannot do
this so now i'm going to do a little bit
of tough love on some people that i like
okay so as i mentioned at the top of the
show yesterday there were a bunch of
primaries across the nation yesterday
one of the primaries was the california
gubernatorial primary so first off i'm
mentioning california so i will put more
money in the jar here and eventually we
will send a democrat out of florida very
exciting uh but a guy who i consider a
friend who is a good decent human being
an environmentalist and an activist
michael schellenberger he ran as an
independent against gavin newsom
i've had him on the show twice he's had
dinner at my house so michael hopefully
if you see this clip you will realize i
am not attacking you personally i'm
talking about tactics right now so gavin
newsom won by a landslide last night
believe it or not the people of
california they want more of this
nonsense so schellenberger sent out a
tweet once the results came in he said
dear friends and allies i am sad to say
we did not receive enough votes to make
the runoff built to rescue our shared
humanity and excited about what we will
do together next now okay i just want to
say one more time i like michael i think
fighting the good fight is a valuable
thing as you guys know when i lived in
california i fought the good fight i
fought for the california recall
election i campaigned with larry elder i
believe that good people should stay and
fight to the best of their ability so
what i what i'm really framing this
around right now is results if you keep
going to something that does not work as
opposed to looking in a different
direction and going oh there are greener
pastures over there there are people
that i can ally with over there
then then
at some point the product is not good
anymore and that's what i would say the
product of liberalism uh where the
product of liberalism is at at the
moment it does not work so now let's
show the results of the election last
night
the election gavin newsom so the voting
turnout was extremely low uh gavin
newsom got 1.4 million votes okay this
is the largest most populous state in
the in the union 1.4 million votes
the second and this is who he's going to
run against this guy brian dahl who's
the republican he got about 346 000
votes uh schellenberger came in fourth
with 68 000 votes 68 000 votes
um i mean i i could have run i could
have just said i was running and not
even lived there and i would have got
more than 68 000 votes i don't mean this
as an attack on michael i want to be
very clear on that one more time what i
mean is that those people the people
that voted for you or bill maher who put
you on his show last week or all of the
sort of idw related liberals the
non-woke liberals who are still all
pretending that conservatives are bad
people and republicans are mean or
something like that at some point you
are doing damage you are no longer
doing something good because
the fight is worthy it is worthy it is
worthy and i'm not saying you should
abandon any of your ideals but there's a
difference between having ideals and a
set of values and everything else and
then also at some point you have to put
them into action and if you keep going
in a direction that they don't work and
a populist tells you we're not
interested in this or the machine is so
corrupt that you can't do anything and
you don't say i have to change my
tactics
then there's a problem and i would
juxtapose this with what happened with
larry elder so larry elder during the
recall
larry elder who is a libertarian a
conservative
he got
4.8 million votes in california for the
recall schellenberger got 68 000 votes
trying it the other way larry elder i
mean there there's almost no republicans
in california
but larry elder got almost 5 million
votes in the recall
so that is the problem schellenberger's
politics are probably more in line with
the average california citizen but they
don't show up the progressive virus has
infected these people so the point is
that good liberalism
good liberalism right enlightenment
liberalism it doesn't work within our
political system today
and if you are a good liberal you're in
essence you're a modern conservative and
there's other evidence for this right so
i'm not making this about schellenberger
in any way personally there's plenty of
other evidence about this because you
remember andrew yang andrew yang who
when he was running all the good
non-woke liberals the same people many
of whom were supporting schellenberger
they were all supporting yang and i had
yang on the show i thought he was a
decent guy
uh but to me it was too much big
government stuff and i don't agree with
ubi or whatever but of course i treated
him with respect and i thought it was
there was something refreshing there um
but it was one of those things where it
was obvious to me he was going to have
no real support so all it was really
doing was causing the good liberals
instead of saying oh i'm a good liberal
and i'm going to have to swallow that
horrible red pill and vote for donald
trump and stop this progressive madness
instead i'm going to support andrew yang
and nothing will happen of it thus it
will all be sort of virtue signaling the
same virtue signaling we're always
making fun of the left for so when
andrew yang dropped out remember this
this is from the guardian entrepreneur
andrew yang has dropped out of the race
to become the 2020 democrat presidential
candidate ending an upstart campaign
that rose from complete obscurity to
competitiveness yang ended his campaign
as ballots were still being counted in
the new hampshire primary on tuesday
with early results he had failed to win
even three percent of the vote endings
are hard and i've always had the
intention to stay in this race he told
supporters in manchester i am the math
guy and it's clear from the numbers
we're not going to win this campaign so
there were all these people online and
again all of the good liberals yang's to
do it he's going to moderate them he's
you know it's all going to be andrew
yang and we'll stop the wokesters and he
got less than three percent of the vote
and then dropped out early
so again this isn't necessarily an
attack on yang it certainly is not an
attack on uh michael schellenberger but
the good liberal thing does not work
it's a sad reality as a guy that wrote
my first book was all about that good
liberal thing and it does not work
politically in america today and i think
also you know there's a certain type of
person that that appeals to and a guy
like andrew yang you know he also showed
in subsequent things that he was going
to fold no matter what you may remember
remember about a month and a half ago or
was it might have been even three months
ago at this point when uh the whole
world for three days was calling joe
rogan a racist right because joe rogan
had a couple doctors on who didn't agree
with mainstream narrative about kovid so
then some people dug up times that joe
rogan said the n-word even though he
wasn't saying the edward to be racist
well andrew yang well we've got info
from the hill here former presidential
candidate andrew yang published and then
deleted a tweet on sunday defending joe
rogan the divisive spotify host against
criticism related to his past use of
racial slurs i don't think joe rogan is
a racist the man interacts with and
works with black people literally all
the time yang said a tweet on sunday
afternoon do i know black friends of
joe's who would swear by him yes i do
added yang who appeared on rogan's
podcast in 2019 during his campaign for
president the point is that yang then
deleted that tweet then you know the
progressives started yelling at yang no
rogan is erased then he deleted it
so i'm trying to show you like i think
you see what i'm doing here i'm trying
to paint you some rough picture it's not
just that the the
old liberal thing doesn't work it's like
it's appealing to a certain type of
person that doesn't want to win in a way
or doesn't really want to stand up for
themselves or is so afraid of their own
shadow that they won't dare
go to the promised land right and it's
like i just can't i can't do that
anymore personally and i know that most
of you watching this i know how many of
you trust me i know i've met a lot of
you over the last two months i know an
awful lot of you uh can't do it anymore
either and you and you're sort of i
would say surprising conservatives in a
wide sense of that um the good liberals
cave to the woke left and until they
decide to to think about things a little
bit differently
they're not going to accomplish anything
you may remember this tweet from my
friend jordan peterson not too long ago
i wasn't a conservative until liberals
cow towed
to radicals meaning they folded up they
folded up and of course what i said
there was you're telling me the radicals
didn't make jordan right wing or
conservative what he's saying there is
the good liberals did
the liberals something must be wrong
with liberalism and that weakness
we're not in a time when we can have
that weakness right now so my message to
to anyone that voted for schallenberger
it's not or for michael himself or for
andrew yang or anyone that supports any
of those things or my friends and former
colleagues who used to come on this show
it's like maybe just take a look in the
mirror for a second maybe realize that
the problems right now are not the
conservatives and they're not the
libertarians and that the more that we
say oh we can win these fights and then
we just fold and get no results maybe
there's a better way to do it that
really
is my message join the right they have
cookies there's nothing left to moderate
over there
once we win and we get the country back
then we'll see what we can do over there
we really can and we'll hash out all the
differences on the right but we got
bigger fish to fry at the moment as they
say i think we're rolling into perhaps
our longest show ever right now uh we
got a cold clothes for you in just a
moment but let me get to some locals
comments pang 01 says love the show keep
up the good work i'm trying to move my
family to florida
as a wise uh green man once said there
is no try only do just get here man it's
great i promise you you will not regret
it i have not met anyone that regrets it
do you regret it
he doesn't regret it do you regret it he
doesn't regret it
it's just great here like if you want to
be around happy people in a thriving
community wherever you are in florida
and i've been bouncing all over the
state
like it's all here it's all here and you
know what
it's it's uh it's a little warm right
now a little humid it's
thunderstorms throughout the day and
then and then it's sunny and good and
it's just it's all good it's all good
texas girl 39 says interview was great
love desantis yeah the guy's the real
deal it ain't gonna get better than that
that's the point i don't believe in
worshiping politicians right i don't
think he's anything other than he is i
think he's a good decent man trying to
defend his state and be a model for the
rest of the country and uh and he
deserves our support jumping jeff says
there's something worse than lacking
energy policy it's having an energy
policy that will bankrupt the general
population right so
this is the point it's like are they
intentionally doing it or are they
completely inept i personally am at the
point where i cannot believe that these
people are so inept i believe that when
they tell you that they want to transfer
an economy into a green economy and have
uh
aoc occasional cortexes uh green new
deal or whatever the hell it is it's
like i believe them when they tell you
they're trying to do this and what would
to get us to their green promised land
they might have to wreck the known world
as we know it so i would believe them by
the way janet yellen who we showed
before who's the secretary of the
treasury she was the president of the
economics department at princeton
university this is not a dumb woman now
you may say all of the universities and
especially ivy league they're corrupt
and ridiculous and all of those things
but like this is not an unqualified
woman by by most measures but when she
sits there after we played the video for
you last week of this endless you know
biden and the entire administration uh
inflation's not going to happen it's
going to be transitory nobody's saying
it's going to happen and now they're all
admitting it and basically she's
throwing her hands up and saying well we
hope it'll get better
it's like man
could they possibly be as as inept as
they appear to be it is unclear to
me
this is it 54 minutes people i think our
line yeah i'm getting the thumbs up this
was our longest direct message ever
very exciting i think you're going to
enjoy this cold close i think it will uh
sort of wrap this thing up nicely
together and show you that we had a
chance and perhaps we will have a chance
sometime soon
he said that the middle east would be
better off with qaddafi saddam hussein
and assad in power how does i didn't say
assad but we certainly have not gained
anything with gaddafi and you look at
what happened i mean look at libya look
at
iraq iraq used to be
no terrorist he would kill the
terrorists immediately it was like now
it's the harvard of terrorism
iraq
if you look at iraq from years ago i'm
not saying he was a nice guy he was a
horrible guy but it was a lot better
than it is right now right now iraq is a
training ground for terrorists right now
libya nobody even knows libya frankly
there is no iraq and there is no libya
it's all broken up they have no control
nobody knows what's going on the world
would be better off with saddam hussein
100 and qaddafi in power 100 now as far
as assad is concerned what about the
human rights abuses let's talk about
what you don't think they're happening
now they're worse now than they ever
were people are getting their heads
chopped off they're being drowned
they're right now they're far worse than
they were ever under saddam hussein or
gaddafi i mean look what happened
libya's a catastrophe you look at our
ambassador as an example okay
libya is a disaster iraq is a disaster
syria is a desert the whole middle east
and it all blew up around hillary
clinton
and around barack obama it all blew up
mr vice president thank you thanks for
your time please come back in less than
13 years sir
all right jack thank you very much
all right it's chris but anyway i just
did chris